The media queries used most often for
responsive web design are,
min-width, and max-width.
Max-width rules are applied
any time the viewport width,
is less than the value specified.
For example, max-width 500 pixels
is matched when the viewport is
500 pixels or less.
It's also possible to create queries
based on min device width, or
max device width, but
this is strongly discouraged.
The difference is subtle,
but very important.
Min width, is based on the size
of the browser window.
Where as min device width,
is based on the size of the screen.
In addition using device width,
can prevent content from
adapting on desktops or other desktops
that allow the windows to be resized.
Because the query is based on the actual
device size, not the browser window.
The other reason some browsers, [COUGH],
the Legacy Android browser,
may report the wrong value.